three she has defeated alice lee today
with the white pieces a successful
defense of the black pieces that will be
it for the event alice lee with her back
against the wall and of course we have
the eight-time u.s women's champion
irina crush here with christian irena
first of all uh congratulations such a
dominant display you played the same or
at least you hinted that you want to get
a similar structure and then she
surprised you with this move d4 did you
anticipate that yeah well i did make a
little change for this game because
instead of b3 i played g3 um so that was
a little bit of an innovation
um yeah you know when you play openings
like that you give your opponent like a
wide berth of how to play right it's
very non-forcing play so you know your
preparation is more like general you
know what kind of positions you would
like to get into
um did you surprise me with d4 i mean
not so much
although
i do think after a6 actually yes the
fact that she has the pawn on a6 um
you know basically a loss of a tempo for
black right and in fact like i think
black was playing down many tempos in
this position in general she also played
this move h6 right you know which in
general it has a point to it right like
she doesn't want to play knight f6
bishop g5 but of course it's kind of
suspicious to be giving up that many
tempos with black because um
yeah she's trying to avoid the trade of
pieces here which i definitely would
have played bishop g5
but when i would have not or would i
would have i would have yeah okay um so
when she played h6 i mean i wasn't
shocked but i definitely felt like it
was a bit kind of dubious
this type of play with just too many
tempos given by black like yeah there's
a6 h6 and the tempo that black loses on
having played bishop c5 because once i
play bishop a3 and we get a trade um
that's like three tempos and it it's
black is playing you know with the black
pieces so that's really a boatload of
tempos that white has to play this
bononi structure and you
by definition therefore you're going to
get in this queen side play which is
exactly what happened
and then when going to find
you understand
she alice was completely on the wrong
script she g5 is just another loss of
temperature honestly there's not a move
that i considered at all you know when i
saw it i mean again i wasn't shocked i
thought okay maybe she's you know she's
trying to play more aggressively but you
know it's hard to be aggressive from a
less developed position
so i wasn't like very worried about this
move
um knight g6 and i think this was
actually my one big moment of the game
which was quite cute after i played c5
yeah um after c5 and then i had this big
think about what to do
you know because yeah she's trying to go
like on b5 knight c7
and basically saying okay well
no big deal uh c5 pawn is hanging yeah
yeah and so i really had to figure out
what to do with my knights right in this
position you don't want to play with his
passive knight on c2 for too long but on
the other hand black is threatening g4
and i actually thought on knight a3 she
might go g4
um big you know moment as well because
now you have to figure out where you're
putting your knight
um i was actually probably going to go
to h4 yes sir oh wow yeah okay that
would have stirred the pot a great deal
it's interesting knight takes h4 you
know g takes and she really has to stop
me from getting into c4 so she has to
play bishop e6 okay so this position i
don't know i thought it was
you know unclear right on one hand she
can't really castle short this is that's
an issue so her king is stuck in the
center too
on the other hand you know she's pretty
strong in the center but kind of like if
i had to say intuitively i would feel
that i'm doing pretty well here okay but
at least in this case
she's it's a full
throttled fight
and uh what happened in the game was
just one goal and it was you were making
all of the moves
g4 might have been the moment for him
yeah because as soon as i played queen
b2 that was kind of my concept that if
she doesn't play g4 i'm going to have
now this beautiful square on d2 for my
night so all of my nights are you know
all of them all two of them
yeah working very well and a5 you know
it's interesting like when she played
this move of course i had first seen it
but like
when she played it i was like did i miss
something did i miss that she's getting
some counter play with like queen e7
maybe taking on c5 but then i was like
no my initial impression was right like
she cannot really open up the queen side
with her knight on g6 right because
basically playing down a piece on the
queen side
and so after knight b5 even if she goes
queen e7 and i take on a5
she cannot really take on c5 because
there's also knight c7
kind of small tricky move
yes alejandro had mentioned that as well
that there's this nasty fork yeah that
she's facing
i it's all falling apart for uh black at
this point though because
um
it's
you you're playing on the theater where
you have a majority and
uh
all of your pieces are working and the
knight on g6 is a piece down yeah that's
how i like assert yes
very good and i must say the rest of the
game unfortunately we won't show it just
out of uh respect for alice's fans but
at 12 years old
she got to the final so we respect that
that here she looked like a 12 year you
made her look bad at this game yeah well
you know she had a very tough day
yesterday she did right and so that's a
very way to the important factor i mean
i'm not like surprised that the game
went like this because you just have to
really think about it in the context of
like what a nerve-wracking day she had
yesterday how she
you know it looked like she was going to
win the match pretty easily then she
loses and she loses again that she's
about to be kicked out of the of the
tournament and she came back from that
so she just had a very difficult day
it's hard to maintain your energy right
like she plays such a such a day and
then then she has to prepare again
against me and you know it's it's just
difficult i think energetically i think
that's the way i understand that and as
you described it too in a previous
interview you got that extra free day
waiting for your challenger to appear in
the final so very very good
uh
[Music]
day for you i mean an ideal day perfect
day you'll have to defend the black
pieces tomorrow to win the title
yeah i feel you know one of the nice
things is actually like i was going into
this match like without feeling any sort
of stress at all
you know not not because i don't care
about how i finish the tournament but
because you know it's kind of like a
luxury to play an event without that
feeling of stress you know when like
most of my tournaments the last couple
of years they tend to be like big high
stakes events you know like national
championships or events for the team and
so it's hard to just kind of relax and
enjoy playing you know when the result
is so important and here it was like i
reached a point in the tournament where
it's kind of like in the in the show i
want to be a millionaire right like
you've gotten the 500 000 and now you
can play for the million but you don't
risk anything you don't risk that you
know that amount so it's like now i can
just enjoy playing
well very good luck for you tomorrow as
you round out your tournament very well
done thank you yes
i really just keep showing why